[Narrator:] These are the unwanted. Four dangerous
characters dedicated to bad health.
Whoopy Whooping Cough, Dippy Diphtheria, Roly
Polio, and Locky Lockjaw.
This is his story.
[Locky Lockjaw:] Hey-y-y, an accident and
she scratched herself, huhhuh.
Another victim for me. Hee-hee-hee-hee.
That car, like many others, is contaminated.
[Crash victim:] Really doctor, it's nothing,
it's just a little scratch.
[Doctor:] Have you been protected from lockjaw?
[Crash victim:] Why yes, doctor, my basic immunizations.
And I had a booster about four years ago.
[Doctor:] Fine. Another booster at this time
should give you adequate protection.
[Narrator:] Where will Locky Lockjaw strike next? Anywhere. Protect your family.
Take a tip from Emmy Immunity.
[Emmy Immunity, singing:] Keep your family
safe, every age and size.
Protection can be yours when you immunize.
[End of sequence]
[Countdown to next segment]
[Narrator:] These are the unwanted. Four dangerous
characters dedicated to bad health.
Whoopy Whooping Cough, Locky Lockjaw, Roly
Polio, and Dippy Diphtheria.
This is her story.
[Dippy Diphtheria:] Since I'm an infectious
character,
I think I'll find me a group to mingle with.
[Dippy flies above a school bus.]
Ah ha, a school bus full of children. I'll
wait here 'til it arrives and then, hehehehehee.
[Narrator:] Will Dippy Diphtheria reach this
group? Let's see what will happen.
[Dippy Diphtheria:] Ahh-chooo.
[An immunization shield appears and blocks
the sneeze droplets.]
[Dippy:] Oh dear, another group protected by immunization!
[Narrator:] Where does she go from here? Anywhere.
Protect your family.
Take a tip from Emmy Immunity.
[Emmy Immunity, singing:] Keep your family
safe, every age and size.
Protection can be yours when you immunize.
[End of sequence]
[Countdown to next segment]
[Narrator:] These are the unwanted. Four dangerous
characters dedicated to bad health.
Dippy Diphtheria, Whoopy Whooping Cough, Locky
Lockjaw, and Roly Polio.
Let's see how he works.
He searches for an innocent child to infect.
Whoopy Whooping Cough looks for an opportunity such as this.
While Dippy Diphtheria watches for another
group to infect.
Accidents are what Locky Lockjaw thrives on.
Protection from these diseases is simple.
Immunize.
This baby is protected from polio.
These children from whooping cough.
This group from diphtheria.
And this young lady from lockjaw.
Protect your family. Take a tip from Emmy
Immunity.
[Emmy Immunity, singing:] Keep your family
safe, every age and size.
Protection can be yours when you immunize.
[End of sequence]
[Countdown to next segment]
[Narrator:] These are the unwanted. Four dangerous
characters dedicated to bad health.
Whoopy Whooping Cough, Dippy Diphtheria, Locky
Lockjaw, and Roly Polio.
This is his story.
On a quiet street in a peaceful town, Roly
approaches his intended victim.
[Roly rams through the front door in his wheelchair,
waving a crutch,
and approaches a child playing on the floor.]
[Roly Polio:] Heheheheee.
[Narrator:] Hold it. Will this villain score?
Will Roly Polio infect this innocent child?
Let's find out.
[Roly Polio:] Curses! Another immunized baby.
[Immunization shield has popped up.]
[Narrator:] Roly Polio is forced to retreat again.
Where does he go from here? Anywhere.
Protect your family. Take a tip from Emmy
Immunity.
[Emmy Immunity, singing:] Keep your family
safe, every age and size.
Protection can be yours when you immunize.
[End of sequence]
[Countdown to next segment]
[Narrator:] These are the unwanted. Four dangerous
characters dedicated to bad health.
Dippy Diphtheria, Roly Polio, Locky Lockjaw,
and Whoopy Whooping Cough.
This is his story.
[Whoopy Whooping Cough:] What a perfect day for infecting!
What a setup, a nursery school filled with little children!
[Whoopy Whooping Cough hovers over a group
of pre-school children in their classroom.]
From this angle I can infect six of them.
From here, I can infect twice as many.
[Narrator:] Hold everything. Will Whoopy Whooping
Cough infect this group of innocent children?
We'll soon find out.
[Whoopy Whooping Cough:] Hurrhuhuhuhu. Sheeee....
[Immunization shield appears.]
All them kids have been immunized.
[Narrator:] Where does Whoopy Whooping Cough
go from here? Anywhere.
Protect your family. Take a tip from Emmy
Immunity.
[Emmy Immunity, singing:] Keep your family safe, every age and size.
Protection can be yours when you immunize.
[End of sequence]
[Countdown to next segment]
[Emmy Immunity:] Beware, beware of those villains
over there.
[Three of the infectious villains are seated
on a bench facing Roly Polio.]
[Roly Polio:] I'm Roly Polio, leader of this
clan.
To destroy good health is our dirty plan!
There's Locky Lockjaw, he's my strong right arm.
There's Whoopy Whooping Cough. He sure will do you harm.
And here is Dippy Diphtheria, she really is a pal.
To all of us diseases, she's our pinup gal.
[Narrator:] Beware of these diseases.
Diphtheria, lockjaw, whooping cough, and polio.
[Emmy Immunity, singing:] Keep your family safe, every age and size.
Protection can be yours when you immunize.
[End of sequence]
[Countdown to next segment]
[Narrator:] These are the unwanted. Four dangerous
characters dedicated to bad health.
Whoopy Whooping Cough, Dippy Diphtheria, Locky
Lockjaw, and Roly Polio.
[Roly Polio:] This new family moved into the
neighborhood.
Oh boy, oh boy. The baby hasn't had his basic
immunizations.
And the rest of the family haven't had their
boosters.
Here's a whole family we can infect with one fell swoop.
[Emmy Immunity:] Little does Roly Polio know that today,
the family is completing the protection they need. Here they come now.
[The family leaves the doctor's office, which has a poster of Emmy on the wall.]
[Members of the family are shown outside, watering the lawn, swinging, reading.]
[The diseases launch their attacks, but crash into immunization shields as they try to get near the family.]
[Narrator:] Immunize now.